[Musique]
le 15 août dernier les renforts promis
par le département et le 19 7 400 voler
vers la métropole pour prêter main forte
dans la lutte contre les incendies en
gironde ils étaient dix à s'être porté
volontaire pour participer à cette
opération de solidarité nationale après
21 jours d'intervention le détachement
de sapeurs pompiers réunionnais est
rentré de sa mission ce mardi 6
septembre à l'intégration en général ça
s'est bien passé belle opération
et une grande fierté d'avoir des
collègues le giron des allemands étaient
tous volontaires
donc il ya d'avoir des principes et avec
tout le monde je pense une distance
assez enrichissant tant sur le plan
opérationnel que sur le plan social on a
pu
défendu on trouve vraiment très très
sympa avec l'ensemble des pompiers des
différents départements de métropole au
niveau de l'accueil en a rien à redire
les gens là-bas ce formidable une espèce
de cohésion on n'a jamais voire
franchement on a on a rien à redire sur
sur le côté sur ce côté là
les 10 soldats du feu ont été félicités
pour leur engagement sur cette opération
aujourd'hui nous avons le retour de la
délégation des sapeurs de la région qui
sont rentrés de leur mission de
solidarité nationale en gironde
l'occasion pour le département de les
remercier de les féliciter et également
de dire à quel point le conseil d'état
ce mortal oeuvre pour la solidarité
grâce à ses soldats en tout cas fière
pour nous de les accueillir de partager
ce moment retour d'expérience également
très enrichissant c'est dans une
ambiance conviviale et avec beaucoup de
fierté que les invités ont pu rendre
hommage à l'effort fourni sur le front
par les sapeurs pompiers réunionnais un
effort immortalisé en photo
[Musique]